les échéances de cette semaine sont
décidément nombreuses la coupe du monde
de football législatives et le bac à
partir de jeudi cette année le plus
vieux candidat à 60 18 ans le plus jeune
et vous allez loi très jeune nabila
taboury abdel juillet ils ont tous les
deux présents à gauche quand un cette
année il passe le brevet des collèges à
droite
ian lui c'est le bac qu'il prépare avec
5 en avance à présent passer le vase
il faut être vraiment très fort et
travaillé très dur
montage n'a pour sa part pas du tout un
génie
jousse juste un chiffon doux pour une
étude
son bronze au concours si tu as ton bon
enfant
on revoit le calculateur depuis la 10e
lien est scolarisé au lycée michelet de
nice parmi ses camarades de nombreux
enfants précoces
malgré tout aux yeux des enseignants
yann reste une exception sur nll cet
enfant et d'une rapidité fulgurante qui
peut me poser quelques problèmes mais je
pense que bientôt il dépassera 1
je lui donne quoi à laon 2 1 en 2002
aura des coûts la précocité de yann a
été décelé dès la maternelle avec un
quotient intellectuel largement au
dessus de 130
il a assimilé en cinq ans les programmes
du collège et du lycée ses capacités ne
dispense pas pour autant de réviser
comme n'importe quel candidat au bac aux
hanches aussi stressé pareil je me fonds
dans le 6 juillet révisée autant tout ça
je rentre pas je pense pas que ces
différences de programmes ces deux
bactéries 1000 après quasiment ça me
ferait mal qu'il n'est pas parce que ils
travaillent vraiment avec acharnement
pour la voir pour continuer parce que
pour lui c'est juste une étape pour
pouvoir continuer ça semble d'ailleurs
bien parti il y en a déjà 18 points
d'avance grâce à l'épreuve de français
sollicités par de prestigieux lycée
parisien
il se verrait bien chercheur en
mathématiques fondamentales